what do you think starts the problem
though so it's like if if they went to
these forums or to these YouTube
channels or whatever like something had
to start it where it's different today
than it was 50 years ago what do you
think that is I think you know just with
with the Advent of of social media and
stuff like that and there's there's just
so much like like this Tinder statistics
right it's like if guys aren't using
professional pictures the first thing we
do when a guy signs up for my my week
programs we get in professional pictures
and then Liz and some other girls on the
team pick the top five and then we apply
face app so they're going from like
average photos to Pro photos to the best
five Pro photos to the face app versions
and now they're getting like a night and
day difference in the quantity and
quality of matches whereas you know
before they might have just put up
whatever pictures didn't get the result
and then they see their friend maybe
like one of their cool guy friends he's
getting a lot of girls but they don't
know how to navigate that properly but
then when they look on social media they
see you know all these perfect looking
people and they say well I'm not perfect
looking right now I have these flaws and
people have these different handicaps
they place in themselves where they are
cognizant of all these different flaws
they have and then they think that that
makes them not good enough for the girls
and then that causes the rejection and
that like reinforces the belief and then
it just continues in a cycle right and
people are you know not many people are
called approaching anyways like even
even in your Generation stuff like that
no but it's gotten even less common yeah
much less and with covid and stuff like
this you know not many people were going
out and I I think that even once like
night venues and stuff reopened not as
many people go out anymore and a lot of
clients I work with their ego is like
very tied to approaching a female in
public so if that girl rejects them they
feel horrible about themselves and it's
it's tough for them to go back in and
try again and then if that rejection
happens again and it keeps it's like
it's like a negative momentum and then
they they just usually give up so my job
is to to show them like look you you can
totally do this and show them real
tangible results and then starts a
positive momentum and then they end up
with a place of options and they can
pick the best one for their girlfriend
something like this what do you what do
you think about the men that say they're
afraid to approach because of the metoo
movement
I mean that's a very real thing like I
live in Brazil that stuff's not really
going on over there yet but in the
western Nations it's it's a really bad
thing I just did a video on my Channel
about like in Scotland if you're talking
about like a sexual conquest and a woman
over here is you can be sent to jail you
can be sent to jail yeah it's like a new
thing why yeah and in England too like I
I correct me if I'm wrong but like if
you like cat call go on the street you
can get in trouble now right you can
Google it I don't know I'm pretty sure
that like yeah but it depends like I
have to be something like
I don't know it depends they won't
arrest you they won't arrestable
offenses it says this legislation well
this legis wait this led this
legislation will criminal criminalize
Acts including cat calling and making
offensive gestures and walking too
closely behind something at night yes
like the Scotland thing it's if you
brush up against someone and I've been
in tons of nightclubs right so I spent a
lot of my time in my life for better or
worse but you know inadvertently you're
going to be brushing up against people
when you're packed in into a club and
that's I can put you in jail now in
Scotland if you brush up against someone
so what do you say to guys that are in
countries with laws like that do you
tell them not to approach or what's your
what's your solution as a dating coach I
mean if they I tell them to move if they
can I mean that's pretty extreme but
like in Australia for instance like they
have a new thing where women can change
their mind about consent during sex
and that's you know I have Australian
clients and and they're just terrified
they don't even want to get in a sexual
situation because there's no one there
to witness that so it's just he said she
said right and they're going to take the
side of the girl in a lot of the cases
I'm not saying that like bad stuff
doesn't happen but it makes guys very
apprehensive same with the Scotland
stuff guys were already afraid to go and
approach it now they don't want to have
legal trouble right so as these
countries and what they're trying to do
is combat harassment of women these are
real problems but when they impose these
very strict kind of lockdown measures
then it turns men away from speaking and
leads to the statistics
I'm curious um because you've lived like
everywhere yeah what is your experience
dating in different countries so I lived
in Poland and Ukraine and I often talk
on my channel that the the women are
just much more family oriented it's
almost almost like the US like 50 years
ago so it's like they're more like
feminine elegant
um kind of stronger moral system looking
for kind of family stuff like that
on the flip side of the coin they take
longer to hook up with which was
annoying right like in Ukraine it would
take like two to five dates to to
actually hook up with a girl added
situations where I'd be in a fourth date
in public and they weren't ready to kiss
yet which I've never encountered
anywhere else but there's not a lot of
this you know
um kind of me too stuff that's happening
in the US and happening in in the UK and
stuff like that but again these are very
real problems that need to be addressed
but when they say that you can't speak
about
you know hooking up with a girl with an
earshot of another woman or you can't
brush up against someone even if it was
an accident or stuff like this it starts
to blur the line between you know guys
just living their life versus
potentially encountering trouble and
guys want to err on the side of caution
a lot of cases and the things we've
already discussed about how guys are
already apprehensive that adds to it and
they just figure you know I'm not gonna
even bother with that I'm just gonna
watch corn I guess or I heard stuff like
this that was interesting so you really
think that the metoo movement has
contributed to male sexless sexlessness
yes they don't want the rest yeah
because I because I have access to like
thousands of clients and I hear these
things all the time and you know the
guys in Australia
a lot of them couldn't even leave
because of the you know during the
pandemic but they're really terrified
about getting in a situation where a
girl later says hey I changed my mind
about consent and then what happens from
there right or or a guy you know
approaching a girl and she doesn't like
it maybe in the UK is he now going to
get in trouble right so
as we said not many people were called
approaching to begin with but when you
put these kind of restrictions on guys
are even more intimidated right because
now there's not just rejection there's
also legal consequences has that ever
happened to any of your clients or
someone you know
um getting in trouble for for no I can't
think of any any instances but I think
it's more of uh it just makes people gun
shy yeah it's more that it could it
couldn't yeah yeah they don't want to
you know just the fact that that exists
and makes them just not want to even be
part of that so like why you know they
don't want to put their freedom on the
line or something like that to get a
hookup yeah that's kind of because again
I'm doing the documentary on the court
system here and I'm starting to like
learn
um you don't even have to be married
it's a crazy thing it's just with a kid
um just the [__] that guys go through
um especially with getting access to
their kids and they can get a lot of
false accusations because here
um they're literally paid they're given
free counsel if you accuse a guy of
assault and a lot of the centers here
know that so they encourage the women to
do it
um yeah and even though it doesn't
happen to every guy I have like
listening to these stories I'm like if I
was like I would be so I've heard a lot
of stories like that from clients where
like basically like like women that
cheat for instance if the the husband
finds out like I've heard of a lot of
situations where the guy gets screwed
because the woman just says you know the
guy that hooked up the woman just says
like it was non-consensual just so she
can save the marriage and there's no
consequence on the woman again I'm not
saying like sexual assault doesn't
happen and it's not a real problem but
it's like a nice little like roll of the
dice in in a bunch of case where I know
people specifically where you know it's
like a real danger even even in the U.S
like a guy I had a client where he he
basically like
um had sexually grow in Las Vegas in a
hotel room and she said I paid for the
room like stay the night and he said I'm
gonna leave and she ran down and said oh
you know he he graped me basically and
you know situations like that or if they
cheat and then the partner finds out
it's just very easy to say it wasn't
consensual so they can save the marriage
and they don't care what happens to the
guy's life right and then it just
becomes he said she said yes
curious for the girls if you were in the
position of guys where the laws were
against you I didn't just say something
about it good it's interesting right
and so a lot of people do mention toxic
masculinity but I definitely think the
crisis that's happening and I can see it
it's if I label it is from toxic
feminist feministy I can't really say
the word problem because how do you how
do you expect people to express
themselves when they're scared men boys
are so scared to express themselves to
approach you but the main complaint from
all of my girlfriends or the people that
I know is the man or not being men
enough yeah they're not like literally
approaching exactly but look they're
created there but then when we have laws
like that how can because I'm just
thinking if I was in their point of view
and you guys can tell me if you agree or
disagree but I would be really hesitant
if yeah and then also We complain about
men that wanting to get married but if
you look at the lows in here in the west
I won't get married why would I will get
married and like rest
fifty percent of my income mainly I make
the most out of that income and I don't
think that's fair as well there is there
is a privilege for women and there's a
man privilege as well and I think it's
not even marriage it's um it's just
having a kid exactly that's the crazy
thing I just talk to this guy um the
other day and he wasn't legally married
he just had a kid here
um and what she did was she um went to
like a woman's shelter and basically at
the women's shelter they tell the girls
like what to say about the guy based on
his background I know some of these
people yeah and so um for him he was
Muslim and she basically said that
everything she did the last 10 years she
didn't actually consent to doing because
it was under his control like control
allegedly even though she was fine with
it while they were married yes and then
they don't really get a fair shot in
court yeah and and it took him over a
year to actually get to go to court so
he didn't see his kid for a year with no
evidence yeah yeah and that's normal
yeah and you know what's funny I think
things are changing now after Amber
hurts yeah you know I think the court
and people and judges are kind of like
looking for more evidence and then
thinking okay maybe Are there women are
using this listen I stand up for women I
love women but I think also abusing men
I don't stand for it I think there's
have to be a balance between men
femininity and masculinity and you have
to honor each other you know what you
say is that balance isn't it because I
think there was a movement at one point
where it was believe all women which
goes completely against our tenants of
actual you know innocent unto proven
guilty it was just if a woman says it
then it's and I get it where it's come
from like you said earlier I mean you
know there's been a lot of historical
wrongs against women so there was a real
natural need to you know redress that I
think the pendulum is just swung so full
of to the other way where it's like
everyone's suffering men are suffering
but now women actually suffering because
there are like you say look your friends
are single because men are terrified and
I I I I I I get the cries from some
quarters in society where people say
it's a deliberate thing to actually
completely dismantle relationships
because that almost seems the only
logical explanation is like this almost
like this real concerned effort to
completely dismantle marriage because
there's any way you can explain it to a
certain extent isn't it because some of
the laws are so crazy so stupid I'm so
Sinister there is like that is not
fostering proper relationships proper
marriage and we can see the stats of you
know especially boys from single parent
families I mean my God from crime to
health to life chances to every stat
goes against them so why are we a
society pushing this real almost like an
agenda to split people up as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible